armin laschet er ist durch sein
krisenmanagement nach dem massenhaften
corona ausbruch bei turniers jetzt
massiv unter beschuss geraten kritisiert
wird unter anderem dass der look down zu
spät kam hat er zu zögerlich gehandelt
herr bosbach nein ich teile diese kritik
nicht denn amila steht hat gesagt wir
warten zunächst einmal die ersten
testergebnisse ab auch das was die
experten uns empfehlen und dann hat die
landesregierung noch dann westfalen
zügig gehandelt es ist natürlich immer
leichter im nachhinein zu sagen aber er
hätte sofort in lockdown verkünden
müssen sofort harte maßnahmen ich
persönlich kann verstehen dass armin
laschet wir möchten zunächst einmal die
lage vor ort genau analysieren um dann
entscheidungen zu treffen denn wir
müssen uns immer hineinversetzen in den
zeitpunkt in dem die entscheidungen
getroffen werden mussten im nachhinein
ist es leichter zu sagen das eine oder
andere hätte man auch anders entscheiden
können